the premise of the movie is set in an
advanced futuristic World virtual
reality has become indistinguishable
from The Real World thanks to numerous
modernized Technologies a big tech
company organizes an exclusive virtual
reality game but unknown to the public
whatever happens in the game also
happens in the real world which means if
the player dies in the game he does in
the real world as well one morning eight
civilians from New York City are called
and are provided a chance to win a
hundred thousand dollars given that they
agree to beta test a new virtual reality
game even though the offer is random and
sketchy all eight of them decide to take
it and arrive at the given address upon
meeting each other they find out that
they are all established Gamers the
organizer of the game welcomes them
through a one-way announcement to
minimize the player's interaction with
other humans they are told to sign a
contract before getting dressed in their
armor the players are only allowed to
use each other's gaming names and keep
personal interaction to a minimum they
wear motion suits before getting scanned
and putting on their armor it connects
with their suit and and becomes one with
the player the armor consists of 54
motion sensors that will help the
players function properly in the virtual
world they are designed to let the
players experience the closest possible
experience to Modern Warfare Everyone
Gets Dressed immediately except for one
player named terrorist he is hesitant
because of his name which was supposed
to be ironic he is also doubtful of the
technology they're testing and thinks it
might be harmful the others ask him to
go back home but the doors to the room
don't open it turns out that the game
cannot start without all players joining
eventually terrorist is convinced to
join the others the armor starts and the
room changes completely the white modern
interior is replaced with The Rustic
walls of an abandoned building the
players are shaken because it is almost
like they teleported to some other place
not just the wall but their clothes also
change into army uniforms and their
tattoos and any scarring on their body
vanish one player tries touching the
beer bottles lying around but his hand
goes through them this game sucks
another guy opens his helmet to see
where he is and sure enough he is still
in the same room putting the helmet back
on he joins the other in front of the
window outside a chopper is fighting
battles in the middle of a destroyed
City a player named Reaper is the most
excited out of everyone he has been
dreaming of getting to experience this
level of virtual reality every day his
excitement paints him as a fool in front
of everyone but he doesn't seem to care
that's a true gamer as they wonder what
they should do next the Army Captain
appears and orders them to stand close
everyone is intimidated by the man but
then they realize he is not real when
they take their helmets off they are
back in the white room with no Captain
around the players Amazed by the
technology decide to continue to explore
it they grab a gun each and test firing
at the bottles seeing the players get
irresponsible with the guns the captain
shoots a guy showing them that their
body armor is destroyed with a single
head he warns them not to get hit a
second time and the players assume they
will get eliminated if they do the
captain explains that their building has
been overrun by a group of highly
trained terrorists the player's aim is
to fight them and make it to the ground
floor they are each given a Medi kit
which will help them if they get hurt
the game starts on the 25th floor and
the players start looking around
initially they are excited and not so
careful but it is until a terrorist
suddenly appears in front of them
shooter quickly Dodges and kills the man
revealing that he is a trained soldier
everyone else feels relieved to have
someone like him in the group they are
also a lot more careful after this the
wind takes them to level 24 which has a
high voltage threat involved they get a
bunch of new weapons because as the
levels decrease the dangers increase a
man named Alta gets the first kill and
is thrilled to see blood on the floor he
grows more violent with each shot and
kills many opponents Reaper gets the
least kills and is almost shot by a
terrorist before shooter saves him
however in the process shooter gets shot
and loses his armor a girl named Taylor
reveals that she came to her friend's
place and wasn't supposed to be in the
game she panics and breaks into tears
while another girl named Mustang
Comforts her suddenly the fifth member
of the group Cox gets shot twice he
drops to the ground and cries in pain
everyone else is confused because the
suit is not supposed to make them feel
pain even when Cox takes off his helmet
the pain won't go away he is immediately
injected with the Medicaid which finally
helps him with the pain he is now sure
that the game is not what they think it
is the first gunshot might not do them
any harm but the second one will
definitely kill them some of them think
that they are in a reality show but none
want to continue playing terrorist tries
taking his helmet off before realizing
that he is stuck in a panic Alta starts
blaming shooter for being in on the
death game shooter in turn storms off to
another room what the players do not
know is that the next level game has
already started which means the place is
swarming with terrorists before shooter
knows it he is shot in the back outside
the other players are also attacked but
they manage to Dodge in time Taylor
tries running down to a lower level but
the Game Stops her because they aren't
allowed to go down before they complete
the previous level Reaper thinks fast
and throws a grenade at the enemy
killing them at once when everything
goes silent they return to shooter and
find him dead in the hallway this
confirms that a player's death is
possible and makes everyone nervous they
have to proceed to the next level soon
but terrorists suggests they try taking
their helmets off first a member named
de Chief warns them to stop but [ __ ]
and terrorists don't listen they
forcefully try taking their helmets off
which causes the virtual Captain to get
mad at them he pushes terrorists to the
ground and kicks him repeatedly
commanding him to never try breaking the
rules again the group finally accepts
that the only way to get out alive is by
winning the game they go down two more
floors and reach the 20th the challenge
is to use knives at this level because
the places had a gas leak and any
gunshot will blow the entire thing up
the first few seconds into the game the
chief is almost killed before Alta saves
him he could do anything to survive and
is the most dangerous out of all of them
following his steps the group does great
in the next few levels however they also
lose many medikats through the process
at one point Mustang is left with the
last kit but both Reaper and Cox are
hurt as she deliberates who she should
Dave terrorist comes to their aid and
saves Cox with his last Medicaid as they
pass a few more levels they stopped
harassed the game is getting harder and
they are running out of many kits
rapidly terrorists starts banging a
glass wall trying to get out of the
building he is successful to some level
but is stopped by the virtual Captain he
beats up terrorist and breaks his leg
with a bone protruding out of his leg
Harris is now a burden to the group Alta
suggests they leave him but the others
want to take him along in the end
terrorist hides under a table and asks
everyone else to continue the game he
slowly loses Consciousness and dies
sometime later in the next level the
group struggles the most because they
are outnumbered by the terrorists Taylor
who hasn't had a single kill hides in a
room the entire time the others fight
but by the end of the level she kills a
man and gets ready to kill some more
when they complete the level the group
decides to rest for a while as they chat
about their lives outside of the game
Cox realizes that all of them have no
close family or friends Reaper only has
a grandmother who has Alzheimer's
Mustang's family lives abroad to Chief
is an orphan Taylor wasn't even supposed
to be here and Alta is divorced if any
of them die and never return home no one
would care they are all true Gamers this
might mean that the organizer of the
game selected them hoping to see them
die the information fuels their anger
getting them ready for the next round
upon reaching the next level they find
the captain beating up an enemy prisoner
he reveals that there is a bomb wired
through the foundation of the building
and only the prisoner knows the code to
turn it off their next task is to get
the code out of the prisoner the task is
easier than the rest hence the group
gets to work immediately the chief
pushes buttons that electrocute The
Prisoner when he is at his lowest he
whispers that the code is Pushkin as
soon as Reaper puts the code in the
lights go off when they turn back on a
voice warns them that the explosive has
been triggered and in the next 30
minutes the entire building will blow up
Alta panics and starts blaming Reaper
for putting in the wrong code the only
way to stop the explosion is by shutting
it down manually when they reach the
parking lot which means they only have
30 minutes to go down the next nine
floors Taylor kills the man who gave
them the wrong password before asking
everyone to hurry up Suddenly Alta loses
his mind and starts hitting Reaper out
of frustration he only stops when the
captain gives them an advantage by
opening up the elevator for them it
stops on the fifth floor but closes
before Alta and Reaper can get out they
are nervous at first but realize that
the elevator is taking them further down
they eventually get off on the third
floor when only 25 minutes are left
before detonation Reaper suggests they
wait until others make it downstairs
however Ulta is against the idea he
points a gun at Reaper using him as a
human shield to get to the other side of
the room at this point he just wants to
get out alive and doesn't care if he has
to kill his teammates for it they soon
come across an enemy and Reaper runs out
of ammo at last he is shot and killed
while Alta runs away from behind him in
hiding he cannot help but cry at the
person he is turning into but it doesn't
end his will to live soon the others
arrive having completed the upper two
levels they find Reaper's body but have
no clue that his death was Ulta's fault
they get in position before killing the
rest of the third floor enemies Taylor
goes into the medical room to look for
more Medi kits and finds one however
Alta arrives there at the same time and
tries to take it from her when the two
get into a fight he kills Taylor and
walks away without feeling an ounce of
regret minutes later Cox runs into Alta
and Comforts him thinking that he feels
bad about his friend's death but then he
finds Taylor's dead body and alta's name
written on the wall with her blood upon
finding out that he is the killer Cox
attacks the guy and the two get into a
fight at one point Cox hits Ulta with a
fire extinguisher which makes the
captain believe that Alta is trying to
take his helmet off because they had
already been warned Alta is attacked and
strangled to death as punishments now
only Cox Mustang and the chief are left
out of all eight players they gear up
and run down to the first floor finally
reaching the parking lot it is filled
with enemies who fire at them repeatedly
as the group bravely moves forward Cox
is shot he has a medicate to save
himself but before he uses it he sees
Mustang being shot as as well Cox
doesn't even think before using the last
kit on her and dying himself in her
place with only seconds left before the
explosive goes off the chief runs
towards it and shuts it down at the last
second the helmet stopped working and
the two are transported back to the
White Room the chief is suddenly
surrounded by a group of soldiers but
doesn't seem surprised this is when we
find out that he is the organizer of the
game who plays with people's lives for
fun before Mustang can react she is
sedated and taken away we see the data
about the dead players being permanently
deleted to get rid of the evidence of
their death the scene changes to the
actual parking lot of the building
Mustang lies unconscious as the dead
bodies of her friends are put in body
bags to be disposed of when she wakes up
the chief stands in front of her with a
bag full of prize money he wants her to
forget about what happened and enjoy
life as he does all she has to do is
promise to keep everything a secret and
she will be sedated again and taken home
surprisingly enough Mustang agrees and
wishes him goodbye a man then comes to
sedate her again but Mustang takes him
by surprise and fights back she
eventually overpowers him and shoots out
the lights making the place pitch black
taking advantage of the darkness she
kills all of the chief's men leaving him
with no backup in a final showdown she
throws the bag at the chief not wanting
to use the money that caused so many
deaths at last she walks out of the
building being the only person who makes
it out alive from the game subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching